j'imagine que c'est pour ce qui s'est
passé au motel qu'est ce qui s'est passé
au modèle si vous le savez pas je vais
vous le dire je gardais une boutique
près de la rue aux consignes et le mardi
soir
on a entendu des coups de feu qui
semblait venir de l'allier
la police est arrivée ça s'est mis à
tirer de partout
quand j'ai fini par entrer trois jeunes
avaient été tués non deux roues qu'ils
ont été tués juste avant que vous
arriviez oui vous avez 1 38
n'est ce pas un revolver vous avez un
revolver oui un calibre 38 vous avez
déjà tué quelqu'un non c'est pas moi les
policiers ignorent
nous y voilà moi c'est ma guerre et la
violence
nationale ont été mobilisées je déclare
l'état d'urgence
c'est la guerre ils détruisent toute la
ville je pars du principe que vous êtes
tous impliqués
mais tu parleras jamais tous à temps par
la personne compris c'est clair ces
problèmes
mes listes vont changer
je vous ai dit ce que j'ai pu
je peux vous aider
les gosses vous êtes malade ou quoi
n'hésiteront pas à nous à battre
ce qui compte c'est que vous passiez
l'année
[Musique]
vous voulez rentrer chez vous qu'est ce
qui s'est passé au modèle
[Musique]